[Music]
I was dictating the wrap-up on the
butcher Benton package
I'm lieutenant dick chasin this hadn't
been a routine case and to find the
answer I've had to put a lot of little
pieces together it began on the day most
cases can be called closed it was the
day before the butcher was to be
executed he was visited by his attorney
Paul Lowe in the death house it was at
this first meeting the butcher Benton
case took its first switch that's it
watching the evidence against you so
strong the governor turned down your
appeal
you're a rotten liar low you started
railroading me from the beginning of the
trial and now you're still trying to
throw me curves look I don't blame you
for being edgy but get this straight
I didn't double-cross you I never worked
harder for our client you mean you never
worked harder for a client to get him
sentenced
you're a fool butcher if you hadn't
tried to double-cross queenly Ellis and
Joe Marcella they wouldn't have turned
state's evidence against you but you had
to get greedy you wanted to keep the
whole $600,000 for yourself well the
boys got soaring I don't blame them
it was all your idea you planned the
whole job you hired us when you found
out I'd state state money you decided it
was time for me to die you've got those
two crumbs to turn state's evidence on
me you stinking rotten mouthpiece we
both know that isn't true butcher look
what's the sense of not giving me the
money it's not gonna do you any good
well I'll have the satisfaction of
knowing that nothing in three crumbs are
gonna spend it what about Eva don't you
owe her something you tell me where the
money is I'll see that she gets your
share I've got a different idea I'm
gonna kill you and screamy and Joe and
I'll take care of even myself he's sick
headed heap you're gonna die tomorrow
none of what I said
I'm gonna get you all three of you even
for your butcher that'd be quite a trick
song dead man remember what I said I'm
gonna kill you all three of you
[Music]
back in Los Angeles two men sat on a
barroom listening to a newscaster tell
his headline story
he played up big the butcher's threat to
kill Paulo's Queenie Ellis and Joe
Marcel II for their having turned
state's evidence against him squee me
Ellis didn't seem happy over the
butcher's threat neither did Joe Marcel
II but they had figured once a dead man
always a dead man but this was one time
everyone was in for a surprise including
the entire police department
[Music]
you see the headlines captain teletype
just came in from San Francisco
butchers execution is set for five
o'clock this afternoon like the
newspaper say he still refuses to talk
about that stolen money well I still
have hopes of coming up with something
it's for the drop by for a dick with
butchers execution the department's
marking it case closed that means you'll
be reassigned I spent a whole year
trying to break this case as far as I'm
concerned
butchers death is just the beginning of
course I can't prove it but I think that
Paul Lowe was the top man and even
though I have to keep working on it
while off-duty I'm going to get Lohse
Queenie Ellis and Joe Marcel II don't
play lieutenant officially I've taken
you off of the case unofficially I wish
you luck do me a favor keep me posted
will do thanks John
I headed for Eva Martin she worked in a
local burlesque house I'm a cop and my
job is to ask questions and get answers
so I decided I might as well start again
with her
come in what do you want I'd like to
talk to you Todd you're a cop aren't you
that's a good question I can't even find
a three-ton armored car let alone the
$600,000 and I've been on the case a
year I've told you and I've told you and
I've told you I don't know anything
about the money I never did then who's
gonna be dead in a little while I
thought it might make a difference I
never knew anything about the money call
me dumb I didn't even know Charles
within the rackets until the trial
take it easy kid
[Music]
honey here's your wrap
[Music]
few moments ago butcher Benton without
revealing the whereabouts of the
$600,000 stolen in the armored car
holdup paid for his crimes against
society in the gas chamber at San
Quentin now for a look at the
international scene today baby noise
tears on Benton feel so badly about
Charles if I know maybe I could have
done something how about a drink we
could both you know an artist can drink
while she's working Boise
[Music]
what's that
now what's the matter it's a message
from Charles he told me to open it if
[Music]
all right
[Music]
how about a steak after the show no
thanks not tonight Paul
[Music]
I didn't find out until much later but
Paulo in opening the letter the butcher
had given Eva found a map outlining his
section of the city sewer system and
clearly identified was the spot where
the butcher and hidden the stolen
payroll he replaced it with a $50 bill I
guess he figured $50 to gain six hundred
thousand was not a bad days work and a
few hundred miles away in San Francisco
the case took another switch which
turned the next 72 hours into one long
hideous nightmare dr. Bradshaw a
distinguished biochemist is making
preparations for a final experiment
which he hoped would lead the way to a
cure for cancer
he'd been successful with laboratory
animals the last step called for a human
body and dr. Bradshaw's assistant
quickly made a deal with a local
mortuary and returned to the laboratory
with the dead body of butcher Benton
[Music]
you made good time well I didn't waste
any
I need trouble now I just handed the
money over and moved the body into your
station wagon that was that good get a
syringe
he's in good shape and I hope so we'll
get other blood samples later we'll run
this one through fast right now we live
into the Machine and then raise him
[Music]
ready you mean you're going to give him
two hundred and eighty-seven thousand
volts yes yes I'll get the fluoroscope
set we'll check with that before we
start dissecting turn off the lights
[Music]
there you are oh boy if you respond
properly in my theory is sound you'll be
more famous dead than alive throw the
switch
but wait I thought I saw a pulsation of
the part
dr. Bradshaw is regaining the breeze
you've brought this man back to life the
heart muscle has simply responded to a
terrific electrical shock that's all
[Music]
yes but it does prove that the cells
still function dr. Bradshaw he is alive
a shock reaction it can't last his cells
are multiplying now if your theory is
right we could keep that reaction going
longer but it's worth a try
[Music]
get the body out
get some adrenaline from the supply room
Sanibel nitrite - hurry hurry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe not you mustn't bully your heart
can't stand the strain
now you must lie still please please
easy easy easy
you must these please
dr. Bradshaw his experiment had given
life back to the butcher he tried to
talk but the electrical voltage had
burned out his vocal cords get it hadn't
destroyed his brain he knew who he was
he knew who he hated he stumble about
the room I think he thought only about
kill low squee me and Joe Marcel a
tremendous electrical voltage that dr.
Bradshaw had given the butcher had
increased his cellular structure to the
point where he was no longer a man dr.
Bradshaw experiment had created a
vicious brutal animal with an almost
inconceivable amount of strength dr.
Bradshaw must have believed the
butcher's regained life would last for
only a few minutes therefore instead of
calling for help the doctor decided to
handle his creation alone now easy
battened just relax I'm a doctor I want
to try to help you do you understand me
you're in my laboratory the execution
was carried out you were declared dead I
tried an experiment on you and brought
you back to life although I didn't
intend that now you've had a great shock
now now come and sit down and be quiet
now come on sit down
[Music]
carefully his reactions are violent
highly explain this
each cell must have multiplied a hundred
times perhaps thousands his strength is
unbelievable no no no it's too late for
the amyl nitrate I want to get some
blood samples make some tests I'll find
out what's happened I get me a syringe
[Music]
why won't the needle penetrate the skin
tissue must be nearly a solid mass of
cells how are we gonna get the blood
sample surgically perhaps
[Music]
now you take it easy you can't leave
here now I'm responsible for your being
alive
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
towards the end of this case captain
Lauder and I found out the doctor and
his assistant had been murdered but I'm
getting ahead of my story
the butcher didn't know how he had been
brought back from the dead and he didn't
care all he knew he was alive then this
monster made man started thinking about
Los Angeles
[Music]
on that very night back in Los Angeles I
decided to stop playing detective for a
little while I went to the burlesque
house to ask IVA to have dinner with me
after all the butcher was dead and if I
got lucky
sooner or later I figured Paulo would
lead me to the stolen payroll in a way
that possibility made me even feel
better
[Music]
it's not fair to watch the show for
backstage
next time I'll pay a visit I take it by
that remark you like my routine yeah
you're pretty good what I can't figure
out though is while you stay in a place
like this it shouldn't be hard for
someone like you to get a job in a class
but if you weren't a detective I'd be
willing to bet with a line like that
your next remark would be how about
dinner
well not exactly dinner but a hamburger
might be a good idea if you're asking in
an official capacity I can't say no I'm
off duty for the past six months all
I've ever called you is lieutenant Jason
do you have a person named
dick give me 10 minutes for a quick
change because you just made yourself a
date attendant I mean know something
dick I haven't had hamburger in the
front seat of an automobile with a guy
in a lot of years well from now on we'll
do it more often
it's funny I who is figurative policeman
wasn't really a human being I mean
unless he was arresting someone or
trying to solve a case he was unhappy
showed you how wrong you are in fact
everyone on the force gets fed up
occasionally with the job they do maybe
we're more human than anyone else we see
so much trouble we get to hate the word
but as long as the world's filled with
people it'll have to be men who enforced
the laws what made you join the
department nose making with the
questions no I understand I'd like to
know well it's really a very short story
when I got out of the Air Corps I
knocked around for a while then I went
to work for an oil company one day and
went back to college on the GI Bill just
before graduation I noticed all about
the police department exams it seemed a
pretty good thing to do with your life
so I took the exams passed then went on
from there
if I ask one more question within these
Dan's try and I still part of the trials
bettin investigation I mean right now I
don't think so as far as the
department's concerned when Beckman was
executed the case was mark closed inside
of me that's not good enough
I don't follow well the $600,000 is
still missing and a fast-talking
underworld lawyer like Paul Lowe is
walking around a free man someday no
matter how long it takes I'll get him
and the money until I do the Benton case
for me is not closed give you my word
dicker Charles Benton never told me
anything about the money no I've been
sure that for a long time but how did
you ever get mixed up with anyone like
the butcher his trouble ever started
just happened I had a roommate he used
to date Benton all the time one day she
packed and left for Chicago
bettan carried a torch for and he used
my shoulder to cry on first thing I knew
we were having dinner together and few
weeks later I was labeled by the police
as this number-one suspect and and
Benton's girl but but it was never like
that I made only one mistake I felt
sorry for
you mean until he was arrested for the
robbery and the killing you had no idea
how he earned a living no this is going
to sound crazy but I don't know what
happens then a couple of times and all
we ever talked about was Madge my old
roommate the last time I saw me tried to
get too friendly and that's when I told
him he had the wrong girl but like I
said I already made my mistake what
about the burlesque house how do you two
fit together
you sound like a lot of other people I
left a small town a couple of years ago
because I won a beauty contest and the
first prize was a spring days after
which nothing happened that's right
only it was pretty rough and then one
day I read and I had about girls wanted
for a burlesque show I auditioned I got
the job you know something it's like any
other job if you're looking for trouble
you you can find it even in a school
room well when the screen test didn't
work out though why didn't you go on
home well first you have to have a home
to go back to
my books are dead so nice Angeles was as
good as anyplace else I don't know about
you but 98 shows a day and at this hour
I'm bushed I know what you mean
mind if I Drive you home no and I'll
tell you something else I haven't minded
anything about tonight
not even the hamburger I kept playing
tag with lo
he made four telephone calls three of
them didn't interest me but one did the
one to Joe Marcella
I watched Joe head for his meeting with
Lo and for some unknown reason I began
to get the feeling that this case was
finally about to explode in my favor
look who's calling names least I get a
Squealer us doing I warned you before
all right Harry that's enough I'll take
care of them I want to talk to okay mr.
Lowe
any future business you've got with this
psycho take care of it upstairs in your
office you keep showing around here
sooner or later it's gonna get slugged
Crippler know people shut up sit down
I need a shot bad you'll get one after
I've talked to you sober enough to
understand yeah I run out of dough I
wonder look it used to be the best torch
man in town how I don't think you could
crack a safe if you know the combination
no jobs nobody wants me since I turned
States on Benton that's your doing you
told me all right quit cry I got a job
for you if you can stay off that stuff
long enough you know I can if I've got a
job how much what is it
it's to grind it interview where buy a
weary pull the job
interesting
two grand ain't much other 600,000 the
other expenses aside that money's plenty
of you want to know I get another boy
I'll do it
how soon do you want me to go to work
set it up for tomorrow night call me
before knowing I'm mother
one that's all those jobs up
[Music]
[Music]
butcher was walking slowly toward Los
Angeles he'd traveled through wooded
hills to prevent being seen by anyone
finally he came to a quiet road he
stopped to get his bearings and then he
saw her he saw something else an
automobile for the butcher that rang a
bell with a car he knew by the next
afternoon he'd be in Los Angeles and
plenty of time to catch up with the
three men who had double-crossed him
[Music]
well see you a real gentleman to be
helping strangers in distress I hope you
don't mind me using the babe here is
bait why did this agency but that's what
she gets paid for bait that is yes she's
a real shaker honest - my outfit
carnival man myself
just call me Connie yeah well friend we
were a little bit of difficulty here got
a flat tire brand-new car no tools in
the back why some of these dealers make
my carnival goodness look like babes in
the woods
[Music]
sound Gilhooley say who you wish break
and let it down let it down
no matter who you with friend believe me
I can do better for both of us I'll make
a fortune for the both of us
[Music]
an hour later the San Francisco Police
Department sent out an APB
[Music]
squads were sent to various parts of the
countryside
[Music]
roadblocks were thrown up to catch the
cold-blooded killer the hysterical girl
had described each squad kept reporting
back to central headquarters and each of
their stories was the same so far none
of them had spotted the car the killer
was driving orders were given to shoot
to kill because from the girls further
accounts they realized they were dealing
with a maniac
[Music]
[Music]
I trust disinformation answer all of
your questions if I can be of any
further service let me know
sincerely ji louder captain police la
there's another all-points of CHP in
these reports sound like they come from
a bunch of loonies sure do
there it is sergeant I want lieutenant
Jason to look these over as soon as he
comes in all right the next morning I
read the stories of the brutal murder of
the two police officers I also read the
witness's statement about the bullets
having no effect upon the killer I felt
sorry for the witness and I thought
about how easily a person's mind can
become confused when suddenly they
receive a brutal shock I didn't believe
a man existed who did not be stopped by
a slug from a 45 good morning captain
you and the rest of the force are going
on 24-hour duty Sina headlines we this
guy that's running a mock up North
latest report he's killed two police
officers made a getaway in a green coupe
heading south I've got a hunch this
killer is gonna be our baby it could be
in town right now yeah you better get
started with Tennant okay any new leads
on that hole it might I think the girl
can probably be counted out if any of
the others are wise they're keeping
mighty quiet let it ride for now the old
force is gonna be on the spot until we
catch this killer newspapers will have a
field day
[Music]
we were wrong about two things
the killer was already in our city and
we didn't know he was butcher Benton he
headed straight for Eva Martin he went
to her dressing room to get back the map
he had left in the envelope with her he
wanted first to check his money then
catch up with Lo and the others
[Music]
can't be
[Music]
you do look like
my different somehow
[Music]
is you fighting somebody tell me
[Music]
this happened shock look like bullet
holes are they
there's even a mark
[Music]
I opened it like you told me I found the
$50 I didn't know why you left him a
positive no why he was here
[Music]
okay crazy the name of Paul triggered
his hate he left her dressing room
started for squee me Ellis and Joe
Marcela's place because he knew with
them out of the way Paul Lowe couldn't
open the strongbox where the money was
hidden
he thought of squee me and Joe first he
was saving Paul Lowe for last
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey can I borrow your eyebrow pencil
[Music]
operator get me police headquarters but
in a Chasen please
when you expect tell him Charles Benton
is alive and and even bullets can't stop
him I'm not crazy
[Music]
just say a friend of Charles Hill no
[Music]
after leaving a message for me even
telephones Queenie Ellis she tried to
tell him the butcher was alive and on
his way over to kill him squee me didn't
believe her and in a way you couldn't
blame him who in their right mind would
believe a man had returned from the dead
what's Queenie actually believed was
that the butcher before his execution
had hired a killer to carry out his
threat
[Music]
you're sick what you don't look so good
to me all right
savor I could take over the matinee
trick for you what it's easy
Ava I can do it step up to doo doo doo
oh um I think I just thought of
something
yeah Eva agreed to let Franz sing to the
show she hoped she'd be able to
interrupt the butcher before he arrived
at squee mise hotel or failing that at
least be able to warn him to stay out of
sight you want to meet captain yeah I
just had to run down on those
fingerprints that stolen car up north I
got nothing on the driver who was killed
with a woman with him take a good look
at these there's something funny about
these yeah the boys in the lab can't
figure it out either those are the
killer's they were found on the steering
wheel looked like they'd been stamped in
with a steel die and I sure do these are
butcher Benton's what they look the same
to me how did the lab boys explain that
I don't their best guess is a twin
brother an identical twin could have the
same pattern of whirls with only slight
variations
ever hear of the butcher having a twin
brother no even if he did it wouldn't
explain these freak prints you didn't
pick up your message lieutenant some
wacky Dame calls you and she says
Charles Benton is alive and bullets
won't stop him if we buy the twin theory
who was she
what'd she seem well she wouldn't leave
her name it sounded kind of hysterical
to me said she was a friend of the
butcher's Eva Martin get on with the
follies and see what that girl knows
yeah
some guys have all the luck I never do
an assign with the follies
meanwhile the butcher headed for
squeemish hotel he didn't seem to be in
any particular hurry actually seemed
like any normal person on his way to
work on his way home
[Music]
he rode up angels flight arrived at the
top scanned the hotel building and then
noticed the only exit from squeemish
apartment the fire escape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the butcher was figuring his next step
and as he looked at the dead cop he
thought about Paulo the next man on his
list CEO Mike Kelly - last night when I
told him I didn't want around here no
more
give me a shot look you need help just
find out if better higher to kill to get
me sad to joke too much then let's drink
up and get out I don't want no trouble
around my place you're a real pal drink
up and get out I said
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
operator get me the police
[Applause]
what's happened guy named squee me got
thrown from the fifth floor he's dead on
a mackerel customer of mine you means
Queenie Ellis yeah that's it just I mean
no one else was killed a one enough
I tell you the bullets never even faced
and he must have been wearing a
bulletproof vest god help us the papers
get ahold of this keep an officer on
duty here to be here for me we're gonna
stake out on Joe Morelli I'd like to
talk to Joe water I'm gonna call San
Quentin suppose Benton is alive every
available man has been put on the case
now yes sir all right all right
anything new report on dr. Bradshaw
owner of the station wagon the San
Francisco police located his laboratory
in the basement of an electrical power
receiving station not sure what's he
know he's dead and another man - his
assistant the lab is a shambles but now
we're getting some action from San
Francisco bet his body never arrived at
the mortuary where it was supposed to go
and attendant there finally broke down
admitted he picked up some quick cash by
handing the body over to a man he was
unable to identify the man was driving a
station wagon
blasted man the Chiefs on my neck and
the commissioners are on his and the
mayor's on theirs
now am I supposed to tell them that our
killer is a dead man they found a
notebook in Bradshaw's lab it ties his
experiments in with a professor Dwiggins
at Caltech I hope to hear from Dwiggins
soon captain before from the valley on
the hysterical woman reports the
presence the killer there's the location
let's go
[Music]
you and your boyfriend had a little
fight make it out of the car to take a
walk you notice that he walked down
toward the somewhere in the direction
where you've seen those lights a short
while before what happened then miss
please try to tell us well I just sit
there a few minutes I guess I was pretty
mad and there was a loud crash like like
heavy metal sort of from down here I got
out of the car to get a better look I
heard Jimmy cry out something up I
couldn't make out the words then down
here look patch of light was Jimmy and
coming toward him was with this man big
man lifted Jimmy up over his head like
like you didn't weigh a thing Jimmy
screamed just once every rope Jimmy's
back
[Music]
you know I started running for I found
this house they let me get the phone
[Music]
thank you my will see that you go Oh
[Music]
Molly see that the young lady gets home
already
Paul lo while driving to his office
heard a radio commentator report the
murder of Joe Marcel II and what shocked
him most was when the broadcast
identified the killer as possibly being
the butcher low headed straight for Eva
Martin at the burlesque theater he
kidney is darkness to low what are you
doing here where's even well I'm taking
her place I'm gonna wear our costumes
what's it you I asked you where's Eva
hey don't get physical and watch your
tone of voice buster I told you little
Eva isn't here I could see that for
myself where is she she's at police
headquarters that's where she is
yes sir the no sir captain Lauder still
with the mayor the killer dropped out of
sight he was last seen in the Hollywood
area yes sir we know he's dangerous
every angles being covered yes sir I'll
tell him
yes see how these fit lower he knows I'm
sorry it's the best our wardrobe
department can afford the idea I assume
the captain will be BAE now look I'm
gonna see the captain about the way here
all night Oh Charles kills Queenie and
jo-jo to Benton he's alive I saw him but
nobody will believe me
I'm checking it my guess is whoever
killed them is on the trail of the money
low now maybe you better start talking
if you know anything about it I don't
know anything did the butcher have a
brother no no brother it was Charles I
saw the tattoo on his arm look I can I'd
police protection where's the money low
you heard yeah demand protection I know
my rights
we put stakeouts on your office at home
that's not enough it's enough as far as
we're concerned what now you're gonna
put me sergeant Dan throw away the key
thank you come up with anything yet dick
we've checked every hotel motel and
rooming house in town we've run a
cross-check on every hangout butcher
ever used net results blank this is
incredible we not only discover a dead
man turned killer but it's beginning to
look like he plays ghost 2
he's somewhere in this city and if we
have to take it apart brick by brick
we've got to get him I may be way off
but I think Paul Lowe could tell us a
lot maybe it's just since she's not
going to suppose he had no alternative
you better grab some coffee your minds
beginning to play tricks on you no now
wait a minute
when Lowe came to us for police
protection it was because he was scared
stiff the butcher would add him to the
list of squee me Alice and Joe Marcella
go on it figures to when he slugged the
sergeant he knew we'd book him right
away
so this Lowe's a pretty cute character
but we can play the same game you mean
will threaten to release him well not
exactly you tell him you realize that he
was excited that throwing the punch was
accidental tell him we're not going to
make a charge that he's completely
released lieutenant you know we can't do
that
Lowell made his first mistake when he
hit the sergeant and let her get him a
year as far as the department's
concerned at least it's a small victory
if my hunch is right Lowe won't want to
be on the streets with the butcher
looking for him and he may talk and talk
a lot enough maybe for us to get rid of
him permanently even lead us to the
butcher if he's frightened enough that
might work but if it doesn't know dick
I'm not gonna release him I want him out
of my way so bad I can taste it but not
bad enough to be responsible for getting
him killed
the good thing about that captain is the
fact we know it but Lowe doesn't let's
give it a try
all right Lowe come on out
I think you'll find everything in there
you're free to go mr. Lowell wait a
minute who do you think you're kidding
you arrested me for assaulting an
officer Court I'll plead guilty with
luck I might get off with six months for
a lawyer you're forgetting a very
important point if no charge is made
there's no trial it was a tough day for
everyone we figured your nerves were on
edge when you threw the punch you didn't
know what you were doing
I've squared everything with a sergeant
it's all over all forgotten
yeah why'd you bring a stenographer
simply because I wanted a record of our
conversation at the time of your release
okay low let's go oh wait a minute
what's that on those streets and I'm a
dead man
you let me go you'll be responsible for
murder don't come off at low you're
imagining things
you know the butcher threatened to kill
me you set me free he'll do it well
that's just a risk we'll have to take
but the way I look at it mr. Lowell
you'll be okay look captain I'll make a
deal with you you keep me here and I'll
tell you how to recover the money maybe
even catch the butcher no deals long
you'd probably tell us anything just to
stall for time come on let's get out of
here no wait a minute all right
I'll tell you the truth start taking
this down
[Applause]
i Paulo hired butcher Benton
screaming Ellis and Joe Miceli to pull
off the armored car holdup and then lo
continued with his confession he told us
about finding the map he showed us the
exact location of where the butcher had
hidden the stolen payroll and he gave us
a most important answer the explanation
as to how the butcher was able to elude
detection his means of escape was the
sewer system the entire city
[Music]
the department went to work fast every
police squad in the city was detailed to
cover a specific area every entrance and
exit to the Los Angeles City sewer
system of 700 miles was covered Captain
Lauder and I along with several other
squads headed for the entrance where
according to the math butcher had given
the money our job was to stop it
and that made me think of one specific
question when we found him that this
monster be stopped I for one wasn't sure
[Music]
everything all set lieutenant
city engineers mapped out each possible
exit the squad of officers are spotted
at every point the butcher can be caught
now's the time after I talked to Caltech
I called on a fire department for a
little help
the professor's thought a flame soar
might stop him flamethrower I suppose
there boys have had a chance to join our
squads by now see we have one with us
here have you thought about what will
happen if this doesn't work no I've been
praying too hard that it will work
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is where we split up I'll go
straight ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
this Maps right we're off our course
we'll have to backtrack
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I didn't have it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and the tremendous shock of electricity
that brought the butcher back to life
destroyed it the $600,000 stolen in the
armored truck robbery has been recovered
case closed
well here the scientists comments for
your records I had to fill in a few
spots with my old guesses but I guess
that's about the size of it do you get
any sleep
Oh some not much how was the girl today
well I called the hospital about an hour
ago she'd gone gone where she told him
she was a working girl and that she'd
been away from the job too long already
quite a girl yeah say how about that
time off I've got coming 48 hours
beginning right now isn't resting
[Music]
know something they in the past 72 hours
seem like a bad dream that rest in the
hospital today really gave me a new
lease on life now that it's over I I
can't believe it actually happen the
important thing is to remember it is all
over I suppose you will be assigned to
another case now I'll have to give up
hamburgers in the front seat of the car
for steaks in a restaurant no I've
thought about that in fact I decided to
do something about it
I started by talking the captain into a
short holiday and just about an hour ago
I got you fired what what did you do
that for I figured that being my wife
would take up all of your time
[Music]
even if I wanted to say no I couldn't
you're not supposed to say no to a
detective I figured that too
[Music]
[Applause]